Now let me actually talk
a little bit about warping and
we are going to get into lot more
detail about this in the next lesson.
So here basically,
I'm just showing you two images.
Right, so I have a point here and I
want to generate a larger point which is
being rotated in the new word image
space where the domain is x prime,
y prime so this may coordinate xs, and
of course, I have my transformation.
So I take this pixel and
I warp it to this location here.
So in essence,
what we're doing is sending each pixel
from f(x,y) to its corresponding
location with a transformation
T(x,y) in the second image.
What happens if the new pixel
lands between two pixels?
Remember, this could be much bigger in
this open space that we coming up with.
In that sense,
we're taking a bigger image and
filling information from there.
In the forward mapping, what's really
done is that we would distribute
the color among the neighborhood pixels.
So, if this is the pixel I have there,
and it shows up there, I would kind of
distribute the color in the ones
around it to generate a new pixel.
And that's what I would actually do.
This is the forward warping process.
Another well-known process is when we
actually go inwards, backward warping.
Again, I take a pixel from here,
and I want to go and
figure out the inverse transformation to
find where would it actually end up, and
what would I do with it.
So again in this, what I will do is take
each pixel from the warped image and
find its corresponding location, and
move it to a new image as
long as I know the inverse.
Again, in this case, what happens
if it shows up in between pixels?
In this case,
what we would do is basically we
will interpolate the color values.
Those where we were redistributing.
Here we would interpolate
the color values and
fill it in here from the neighbors.
Again, how do we do this interpolation?
Remember how we did things like
filtering images and stuff like that.
We could use those types of
methods to help us do this.
Just to do a quick comparison,
forward versus inverse warping.
Which one do you think is better?
Well usually,
inverse mapping is a better map that,
because it eliminates holes.
We're always going from
something we know how to get to,
to much more of an original image.
And of course that allows us to
fill in all the color information.
If you sometimes go from one to the
other, we might run into places where we
don't have,
we'll have to do some sort of hole fill.
I'll talk a little a bit about
that when we talk about morphing.
But, the important part
is to do inverse warping,
we need an invertible warp function.
Now I want you all to think about how
we would actually create an invertible
warp function based on what
we've talked about before.
And see that in some instances,
especially for rigid warps and
stuff like that, that's the easily
computable inverse functions.
Especially when you have rotations and
translations and you're doing scales.
It does get harder when you do
a bunch of other things and
not all the time especially when
you do have, not a global warp.
It gets harder and
harder to compute those.